i've never seen an empty greenhouse in
in 14 years it's uh it's the first time
anything like this has happened and it's
depressing
this this is something that will
you don't just lose a bit of money here
this is something that can ruin a
business
[Music]
in our homes
our businesses are places of work
this cost of living crisis is now a
reality
forcing families to trade hunger for
warmth
paralyzing businesses
but how did it come to this
this shouldn't look like this should it
no this this should be full of plants it
should be full of cucumber plants the
grower prepared it in february in the
hope that the gas price would come down
it didn't so
it's laying where as it is
it's time to stop
pause
and rewind
from the foods we eat to the products we
consume and the services we rely on
let's trace this back down supply chains
through the economy to where it began
and that means going to the very
beginning to ground zero
[Music]
let's begin with one of life's staples
have you ever wondered where salt comes
from well we are here in picturesque
cheshire and 400 meters beneath our feet
is an enormous slab of salt and
compressed air and water are being sent
down
that gets pumped out and so begins a
long journey that tells you an awful lot
about the cost of living crisis
that brine is pumped under the ground
and cast iron pipes along to hear
british salt in middlewich that's the
salty water being filtered and purified
in these big fats
then it flows into here these enormous
evaporation vessels where it's heated
and heated and heated again eventually
you're left with this pure dried vacuum
salt this will soon end up on your
kitchen table and inside your body
but the point here is that making salt
involves burning natural gas and lots of
it salt is in part a fossil fuel product
which helps explain why these prices are
going up up by 13 in the past year alone
the process is massively energy
intensive so the evaporation process
relies on um
on a steam input that's derived from
from natural gas in the boiler process
um typically demanding around 45 tonnes
an hour of steam
in order to
to reduce that moisture content so
you're a big use of natural gas and
natural gas is by far away our biggest
manufacturing cost you see energy costs
aren't just in energy they're in salt
they're in basic materials they're
everywhere coursing through supply
chains like an economic shock wave and
this isn't the first time we face shock
waves like these
when you get an intellectual mistake
in policy
and you allow inflation to start to rise
if you're then hit by bad luck
which is what happened in the 1970s and
has happened now
it becomes something of a
very unpleasant outcome
and it takes tough action and it's not a
pleasant period through which we're
going to have to go
an unpleasant period defined by higher
prices not just of salt but other foods
as well but why are they going up it
couldn't be the same reason could it
cucumbers and tomatoes couldn't be
fossil fuel products too could they well
let's have a look shall we
here in the lee valley they grow all
those kinds of things under acres and
acres of glass
so in this block here we're growing a
cherry tomato cherry on the vine it's
called axiani yeah so we've got the
blocky peppers the bell pepper and some
pointed peppers and some snack peppers
little
baby peppers sweet
now before we go any further take a
closer look at these pipes they are what
heat the greenhouse keeping it at an
optimal temperature for those tomatoes
and what heats the pipes
this hulking natural gas boiler and the
price of natural gas is up anywhere
between 60 and 600 percent in the past
year but that's not all because not only
is the boiler heating the greenhouse the
co2 from its chimneys is also being
pumped into here to increase the rate of
photosynthesis so the tomatoes grow
faster and there's more because the
fertilizer those piles of bags waiting
to be mixed and pumped into the
greenhouse is also made from natural gas
and fertilizer inflation that's running
at 47
you see where we're heading here
obviously gas has always been a big a
big expense in uh in a
nursery this size but in the last
six nine months it's been
astronomical really the the the price
increase that we've seen in the last 12
months
has gone from say 40 pence per firm to
we've seen four pound we've even hit
eight pound per therm on a day price and
can you recall any time like her no no
no no no no i don't think anybody has a
little bit
no i mean
i i've not seen not to this extreme
there are others they did not want to
take the gamble that we took on on
planting um they left their glass house
empty they left their greenhouses empty
which um you know if i look at it now
they they've made a great decision but
oh really do you think it was the wrong
decision to
as it's going i can't tell until the end
of the year comes when we see what
happens and what we've produced and if
we get any help i couldn't tell you if
it's the right decision now
further down the valley of lush verdant
greenhouses you see this
white emptiness
for the first time in living memory half
the greenhouses here have been left
fallow by growers who simply couldn't
afford the energy costs
that brings us back to where we started
how significant a decision is if you're
a grower here you know
taking that leap to leave this place
empty
well i mean all of our growers are
family businesses and they've been
established here for 70 years um some of
them are third generation growers from
the same family so
it's it's a massive decision to stop
growing because it feels as though
you're you're letting down your your
heritage
often when we talk about a cost of
living crisis the images that go into
your mind are supermarkets prices things
like that but actually it's wider than
that because this is very economically
destructive because people simply can't
do the work they want to do that's what
we're seeing here it's not just a cost
of living crisis it's also a way of
living crisis
the reason for this is is that energy is
actually central to economic life it's
in some sense you know economic activity
is the deployment
of energy
to
try to do more
and so when a shock happens
in the energy sphere then it
necessarily has to run through the whole
of the economy
back in cheshire the salt they make here
doesn't just go into food they use it to
make soda ash and that soda ash goes
into this old plant gets whizzed around
in centrifuges heated and dried in these
pipes and cylinders carbon dioxide is
added and you get sodium bicarbonate
baking soda biscuits cakes and a host of
pharmaceuticals couldn't happen without
this stuff sodium bicarbonate which has
multiple uses but particularly ones
people may be familiar with food in your
kitchen perhaps less familiar
hemodialysis which is key for
kidney treatment pharmaceuticals so we
have a product that can go into tablets
as a ph buffer detergents
even fire extinguishers
but let's just pause again you see those
big towers behind martin that's a
massive natural gas plant and a new
carbon capture facility sending co2 in
to be used in their factories just like
the greenhouse growing tomatoes nothing
here is wasted
read between the lines and you see
what's happening here the price of salt
sodium bicarbonate and soda ash have a
lot further to rise the shock wave
continues
next stop nip on electric glass in wigan
here they make fiber glass and
extraordinary material tiny strands of
glass which will be woven into panels
stronger than steel and incredibly light
but what's glass made from
sand a few other materials and
soda ash the stuff they make in cheshire
those raw materials get loaded into this
furnace and melted down
1600 is the hottest spot which is what
we call chrome temperature
ground temperature which is one of the
most important things that i do is
maintaining that crow
you can actually smell the natural gas
in the air as it gets piped into the
furnace and it is baking hot and it has
to be baking hot because
if you want to turn sand into glass you
need to get up to temperatures of one
and a half thousand degrees there's a
thermodynamic logic to this and we have
yet to come up with a better way a more
efficient way of doing it
than with natural gas
at the end of the furnace the melted
glass comes out as hair thin strands you
can just about see them here it's a
surprisingly labor
process they call this milking the glass
which raises another issue energy and
raw materials aren't the only thing
getting more expensive so too is human
labor
for anyone hoping cheap wind power could
help substitute for expensive gas this
place provides some challenges but you
don't get fiberglass if you instantly
get rid of natural gas
and you need fiberglass for the wind
turbines
they're going to help us get beyond
natural gas yes
five glass at scale is a big process
it's an awful lot of energy
and this presumably is more expensive
just like you know just like your
furnace this is more expensive because
your natural gas costs are higher yes
and they've gone off significantly even
though we've protected ourselves with
hedging um
maybe up to 50 percent more
that we were paying 12 18 months ago
by the way that thing we're standing in
front of is what drives the fiberglass
and only natural gas dryers cure it into
the finished product when you have an
increase in fossil fuel energy prices
particularly perhaps
gas
then you make all the inputs for
you know making the infrastructure for
green energy more expensive too because
you can't produce
solar panels or wind turbines at the
moment without using
fossil fuel energy
at this stage you're probably wondering
well fair enough what about the rest of
the economy which doesn't make stuff
well that's affected too
for instance the chemicals made from
that salt also form the backbone of
things like hair products so this shock
wave also travels down to your local
hairdresser too we're affected it's you
know it's it it's along the supply chain
so you know whether it's a raw material
to go into a product or make a product
package we understand that they pass
that on to the
manufacturer and they pass it on to the
to the brand whichever brand it happens
to be
and
yeah and we end up taking the brunt of
that and we have to make a decision do
we put our prices up what we we've got
we've had a saying for a long time
better off to have some cake than no
cake
all of which is why inflation in this
part of the services sector is running
at 5.5 percent
energy prices sparking a raw materials
crisis and a cost of living nightmare
but there's one final question where did
this shockwave actually begin
think about it gas prices were at record
highs before russia invaded ukraine what
if these shock waves were amplified by
central banks including the bank of
england printing hundreds of billions of
pounds to pump into the economy they
shouldn't have been printing the extra
money what governments were doing
was enough
to deal with the consequences of covid
and that your point is that has
contributed to what we're now seeing in
terms of the cost of living yes it and
it's true you can see it with all
central banks that they're now worried
about inflation when they weren't before
and it's not all the result of the
russian invasion of ukraine this was
foreseeable you think yes it was
foreseeable because
it was a mistaken diagnosis of what
needed to be done with the pandemic
whatever the cause it's now clear what
we're facing
shockwave after shockwave prices
spiraling higher coming your way down
these supply chains the very foundation
of the 21st century economy not just an
energy crisis an everything crisis
it is only just beginning
[Music]